hello everyone here is another game from
the speed chess championship finals
between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura and here you will see something
a theme that was occurring pretty much
in every other game throughout the
entire event Nakamura either got a
better position or a winning position
but it simply wasn't enough he couldn't
convert into a win and Magnus Carlsen
just kept playing the best moves and the
Nakamura didn't find the the best
solutions so here is a game and it's a
very interesting game it's Kings Indian
defense but we're white actually attacks
on the Kings side so something you don't
see very often especially when Nakamura
plays the Kings Indian defense so we
have d4 by Carlson cousin has the white
pieces in this game Knight to f6 c4 g6
the Kings Indian defense Knight to c3
Bishop to g7 key for now d6 Knight to f3
nakamura castles we have h3e 5 d 5 and a
5 by Nakamura Bishop to e3
we have 90 to a 6 and g4 so already you
can see that cousin is ready to push on
the King side he will probably Castle
queenside Knight to d7 preparing 95 we
have night to d2 Knight d2 c5 now and
rook to g1 King to h8 a 3 now Bishop to
d7 and Queen to c2 c6 Carlsen castles
Queen side see captures on d5 seek after
Sun d5 and rock the c8 as the king and
queen are together and on the C file so
King to be won by Colson a for now
preparing knight to come to b3 if that
night on d2 ever moves and h4 by Carlsen
and here as you can see Karsten is ready
to push h5 or maybe g5 and only then h5
and definitely some lines will be open
Bishop is coming either to e2 or d3 the
rooks will probably come to H 1 and G 1
and here a principals move by Nakamura
would probably be something like Queen
to a5 and start pushing his own pawns on
the on the Queen side but here Nakamura
actually won 4
sorry for f5 and this doesn't seem well
the constant is attacking on the
kingside your king is on the kingside
you don't really want to open open up
too much on the kingside that's called
cousin Castle queenside but it's not
without any poison if you if each
character's an f5 and G characters on f5
you can't really capture as your king
and queen er on this nice diagonal so
this would lose material for Carlsen
for example 92b for simply capture it
this knight is pinned from the rook and
c8 but after this f5 move cousin ignores
this and pushes h5 we have f4 Bishop
captures on c5 Knight captures on c5 and
now H captures on g 6h capture sin g6
and the g5 now for more control over the
dark squares and this poem will pretty
much stop this Bishop and queen from
interfering with Carlson's plans on the
Kings side rook to f7 we have Bishop to
b5 now calls and wants to exchange this
LightSquared Bishop King back to g8 not
allowing any rock to h1 checks which
tempo Bishop captures Queen captures and
Knight to c4 now both of Carson's
Knights are coming for this d6 pawn
Queen to d8 we have night the b5 now and
Bishop to f8 now protecting that pawn on
d6 rook to h1 we have Queen to d7 Knight
back to c3 rook the c7 and nights to b6
now again with a temple on the Queen
Queen e8 we have f3 now adding more
protection to d4 pawn also preparing
ideas like Queen to h2 check and it's a
very interesting position here nakamura
knows that carlson wants to go for Queen
h2 check he plays Knight to b3 we have
Knight captures on a for Carson grabs
that pawn and nakamura
develops a devious plan how to stop
Queen - H - he plays Knight to the d4
attacking the Queen and here Carlsen
probably should have gone for something
like Queen to b3 but Carson plays Queen
to h2 and this is actually a blunder a
Nakamura plays rook to h7 attacking
Queen and now calls and retreats queen -
f - but now this is why Queen - H - was
impossible
knock-knock more a place b v and magnus
carlsen loses a piece as you can see
this night that doesn't really have
anywhere to go the b5 point is protected
by the d4 Knight cross and does play
Knight to b6 not immediately sorry
first he plays rook captures on age 7 he
exchanges one rook rook captures and now
Knight to b6 but here is the problem
Queen to d8 and the knight is trapped
the Knight has nowhere to go so here
Carlsen played nice capture some b5
grabbing another pawn Knight capture
some b5 and now Knight back to c4 Knight
the d4 would have Queen to g2 rook to c7
quicker rook to c1 defending the knight
Queen to c8 with a double attack on the
night and here Queen to f1 cross and
defense tonight and nakamura plays
Knight to b3 here it's hard to say if
nakamura missed as it's fairly simple
Knight captures on f3 after Queen
captures simply rook captures on f4 you
you still have an extra piece but I
don't actually think
nakamura missed this I think that this
extra piece he has on f8 isn't really
doing that much it is a winning position
for black but how do you stop with the
two passed pawns with this bishop that
can't really go anywhere you can't go
through this this pawn as it's blocked
and here your own pawn is blocked by the
g5 phone calls and pushed so the
Nakamura is up a piece but it's not a
very good piece for now
so after this Queen to f1 I don't think
nakamura missed Knight captures on f3 I
think he just didn't want to play
against these two passed pawns
so Knight to b3 route the c3 and now
Knight to d4 King - a - Queen to a6 we
have Queen to b3
Queen to a7 now Knight - D - Bishop to
e7 trying now to get the bishop into the
game as a bishop or capture the g5 pawn
rook rook captures on c7 Queen captures
on c7 amount Knights to be three and
here again called Nakamura can go for
simplifications with tonight capture
screen captures and Bishop captures
Angie
five it's a completely winning position
for black but again he decides not to do
probably still because he doesn't want
to face those two best bones Carlson has
Queen to c2 now he wants to exchange
Queens this way and of course and of
course does this Queen captures Knight
captures and Knight to a5 and Bishop
captures on g5 here Nakamura grabs upon
this still is a winning position for
black but a better idea would be to play
Knight to e1 and go for this f3 pawn
after you grab that that phone you have
this past f4 pawn and the past f4 point
is a lot closer than the past G pawn I
mean even if you capture on g5 you still
have to push this pawn after we exchange
again you're probably gonna go for
promoting the f1 so maybe 91 capturing
on f3 was better but okay after Knight
a5 Nakamura plays Bishop captures on g5
and Knight to c6 now King to f7 and a
for now Carlsen starts pushing his past
pawns on the Queen side Bishop to h4 and
now a5 Bishop - f - B for King to e8 now
King is coming to help out with the
defense b5 now King d7 b6 we have King
to see it and now King to b3 and night
to d4 check crosses simply plays King to
c4 you'd never want to exchange this if
you play Knight captures then you get
three passed pawns and here white is
simply winning you can't stop three-bath
bonds
so after King c4 we have Kings - b7
sorry King to be 798 check by Carson
King to a six and now b7 you can't catch
the a5 pawn because ba it becomes a
queen so King has to go to a 7 and now a
six again you're protecting the a sec
spawned by by the threat of this pawn
being promoted and here if Nakamura went
for Bishop to h4 this Bishop to h4 is
actually the winning move for black you
attack the knight here and after the
knight moves simply play Knight captures
on f3 and it's a much better position as
white simply can't push response this
night will be unable to help out as you
can see this bishop
is covering all of the squares that are
important pretty well so the bishop can
come help out either through e1 or
through through d8 if the knight moves
but after a six
GFI was played and now cross in place at
night to f7 going after the d6 pawn and
so here it's pretty much a draw okay
Nakamura did block his bishop by playing
this g5 move but still after Bishop to
e1 and Knight captures an b6 after
Bishop comes to a5 it's still a draw as
you can see the bishop and Knight are
preventing the White King from entering
the position and this Bishop will be
covering any important squares this
night might use to check the black King
but after this night to f7 move Nakamura
played Bishop to h4 probably threatening
g4g for in the next move but there
simply isn't time for this after this
Bishop to h4 move Carlson is simply
winning and he knows this he plays
Knight captures on d6 we have G for now
but now comes Knight to c8 check King to
b8 and now Knight to b6 and it is in
this position that Hikaru Nakamura
resigned to the game now you can see
that instead of being here this Bishop
should have been on a 5 and from there
there is no Knight b6 idea unfortunately
now that the knight is on B 6 it doesn't
really matter what black place if he
pushes captures on f3 doesn't matter
Carlson has this nice Knight to d7 check
this comes over to check on the whites
where King has to move and now the night
is protecting the queening square Queen
to be a check and it doesn't matter you
can either push the apon to victory
doesn't matter you can even allow blacks
to bring up a queen after Queen a7 this
is checkmate this is perfectly perfectly
winning position for white so yeah after
this night to be 6 mo Nakamura resigned
the game and once again we see that it
simply isn't enough to have a winning
position like so many players say I was
winning in that position but my opponent
won yes your opponent won because he's a
better player that's that's the
unfortunate truth for for all of us it's
never enough to have a better position
you have to
the game either from a better position
either from a worse position doesn't
doesn't matter great great game to learn
from and the funniest thing is this is
actually a bullet game but it's played
so well I mean by Magnus Carlsen and
Nakamura as well
he won a piece but that piece simply
wasn't enough that extra piece was
actually a semi trapped bishop on f8
okay he he could have unwrapped it by
playing something like this and
capturing that the g5 pawn but there
simply wasn't time for this so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I think this is the last game I'll be
covering from this championship unless
you you really want to suggest one more
and then I will check it out as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon